Let's say I only wanted to eat natural food…
what exactly does that mean?
Natural…
Sup sup nature-eaters, Trace back again with
you at DNews.
Recently, the Food and Drug Administration
decided to look into 'natural' as a food label.
We'll see what the FDA decides, but on their
website they specifically say, 'natural' foods
are difficult to define because all food goes
through processing.
They don't object to using natural on a food
if it doesn't have synthetic substances or
artificial flavors, but otherwise?
Pbhht.
Could be anything up in there.
For example, would you say red grapefruit
is natural?
Probably.
It's a tasty breakfast delight.
But, the first red grapefruit was a natural
mutant which lost its color as it matured,
so companies irradiated the seeds of that
red mutant grapefruit creating the Star Ruby
and Rio Red grapefruit in the 1970s and 80s.
Are irradiated mutant fruits 'natural?'
You'd probably think so, until I call them
that.
The problem is, no one knows!
What is natural food?
We probably don't have any!
So now the FDA has quite the task ahead of
them, because they have to decide what 'natural'
means in our food chain.
Almost ALL soybeans and corn are genetically
modified food products, in fact two thirds
of all food in the US is genetically modified
-- and 80 to 90 percent of the bacterial enzymes
which create hard cheeses are too.
Is parmesean not natural?
Is genetically modified food NOT real food
somehow?
In the 1990s, papaya were being devastated
by disease, but genetic modification saved
them, and now 77 percent of all papaya are
GM.
Squash, Zucchini… all have species which
are genetically modified organisms…
Which isn't inherently a bad thing…
Hundreds and hundreds of scientific papers
agree, GMOs are not dangerous, and the World
Health Organization has noted no negative
effects on human health from eating GM foods!
Natural foods are not necessarily better for
you across the board than other foods, it's
the same with organics.
The problem with Internet debates on food
is, food is complicated.
Genetically modified organisms are plants,
animals and microbes where genes have been
artificially inserted in a lab -- NOT through
selective breeding or natural recombination.
But once they're modified, they grow just
like any other thing.
If scientists add genes from a rice crop that
evolved in drought-stricken place to rice
with a high yield, ideally we'd have a drought-resistant
plentiful crop!
And it would grow just like any other rice…
only… more… and in drier places.
Is that natural?
*shrug* Is that good!
In the era of climate change, maybe.
What we commonly hear, is natural foods FEEL
a certain way.
That's just marketing.
The Journal of Business Ethics found when
people touch things that say "fair trade"
or "made with organic ingredients" they feel
better about themselves -- it's called the
positive contagion effect.
They feel as though they're more ethical because
they associate with something they believe
to be ethical.
And maybe that's the crux of this 'natural'
and 'organic' debate!
A 2015 paper in Cell hypothesizes that we
freak out about natural and GMO because we
don't reason, we intuit, we go with our gut!
We use intuition and say, GMOs and cold and
scientific... they're bad, natural feels good!
In all this hubbub a major point is lost -- blanket
statements about global food security and
supply are useless.
All natural foods are not one thing, neither
are all organics or all GMOs.
The World Health Organization said "safety
should be assessed on a case-by-case basis…"
And until the FDA does create a solid definition
of what 'natural' means -- scientists can't
create studies comparing natural to non-natural.
Sure, not all GMOs are above reproach, but
that's more about the admittedly shady agribusinesses,
not necessarily the foods themselves; geneticists
have created tomatoes that resist frost, apples
that don't brown, and salmon that grow faster
for fish farming… all great things in a
planet with a changing climate and growing
population.
Obviously, skepticism in this area is important,
but going with your gut?
That's a good way to eat, but not a good way
to think.
If you love going with your gut and finding
the best of the best in food, check out our
friends over at EATER
How do y'all feel about GMOs and natural vs
regular old food.
Let me know.